بعد نحو اسبوعين على انطلاق المحادثات
السودانيه في جده بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وافقت طرفان على وقف اطلاق النار
مدته اسبوع يبدا غدا مع احتمال تمديده
لاحقا وبانتظار دخول الهدنه حيز التنفيذ
يفترض على كلا الطرفين منذ لحظه توقيع
الاتفاق ولمده 48 ساعه عدم السعي وراء
تحقيق اي مكاسب عسكريه على الارض بمعنى
اخر وقف الاشتباكات تماما يفترض خلال تلك
الفتره اي 48 ساعه ان يبلغ الجيش والدعم
السريع قوتهما بشروط هذا الاتفاق وتوجيهما
الامتثال بوقف النار في جميع انحاء البلاد
على الجانبين اذا وقف كافه الهجمات
والاعمال العدائيه بما في ذلك هجمات
القناصه واستهداف البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
او حتى المراكز السكانيه كذلك تلتزم
القوتان العسكريتان بعدم تقويه الدفاعات
او اعاده الامداد او توزيع الاسلحه او
الامدادات العسكريه بما في ذلك من مصادر
اجنبيه
تمتنعان عن احتلال المستشفيات ومرافق
البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه بما في ذلك منشات
المياه والكهرباء والوقود يتعهد الطرفان
بوقف اي اعمال تتعلق بالاخفاء القصري او
الاحتجاز التعسفي والتعذيب للاشخاص اي
التزام بالقوانين الدوليه المتعلقه بحقوق
الانسان
احنا كشعب سوداني بنعول عليه كثير جدا جدا
اول حاجه ايقاف ايقاف الحرب بين الطرفين
ايقاف اطلاق النار بين الطرفين ويكون
ايقاف لانه عندنا تجارب سابقه
ايقاف النار للاسف اتهزمت قالوا اي قوه
تكون قاعده فيه في مناطق يعني فالدعم
السريع محتل بيوت ناس فقعد في مناطق فيها
يعني كميه مهوله من المواطنين ومن السكان
فالمفروض تراجع الكلام ده تطبق الحاجات
الانسانيه المستشفية للمستشفيات دفن الجثث
وكده لازم يتطبق الناس تقعد في حته واحده
وتتفاوض ويوقف الضرب ها حاجه اسمها الحرب
يوقفوها لانه بعد شويه لمواقفه تنحرف هذه
هتكون حرب اهليه الاتفاق اللي حصل في جده
نغتصب واخف اطلاق النار نتمنى الاتفاق ده
يطبق
النار وقتلا مدينين والخرابه اللي حصل انه
هذه الحرب قدر على اليابسه الاخضر هو اصلا
ما كان الاخضر كان بقى قليل لكن الان هذه
الحرب عليهم محتاجين يعني محتاجين لانه
هي للمواطنين الحياه تسير المواطن يكون في
اطمئنان يكون في حياه طيبه يعني يعيش
الانسان في هذا البلد يعني وهذا الوطن
الوطني كبير وطن عريض لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات